a tennessee man
named bill doris leave five
million dollars to his dog
he said she's a good girl
man man
that's hard to stomach man
hell that's hard to cow stomach and they
got eight stomachs
just the fact that that's what we get
that's what we get humans the way we
want to treat each other
then now the money go to the animal you
want to light your grandmother's
uh little cat's tail on fire we're gonna
see who gets the last
laugh now aren't we when biscuit gets
that
inheritance and suddenly you know you
working for a dalmatian somewhere
times have changed man i'm telling you
you gotta start treating your
grandparents well
oh you don't want to eat nana's banana
bread
well guess who is eating it little petey
it's going it's going to be wild when
you living in a bird cage for the rest
of your life
and petey's out there on his computer
all day on his ameritrade account
it's just where we're at it's where
we're at as people man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one